it's been a pretty difficult week for
the government with the publication of
the sue grey report and you've come out
to back for the government not once but
twice i also interviewed you on
wednesday and the day of the publication
yes yes i was at hillsborough castle i
was just awaiting the arrival of the u.s
delegation to come have dinner and talk
about the issues with the northern
ireland protocol and northern ireland
more generally you've got a bit of a
history though haven't you coming out to
bat for the government on these really
difficult days and i remember talking to
you after matt hancock had been caught
breaking covered rules after market
rashford's free school meal policy i
mean you're hoping that number 10 will
might one day let you out when there's a
good news story to talk about well
actually this week is a as an example
actually we've got a lot of work going
on this week actually northern ireland
we've had the second reading of a very
very important delicate but important
piece of legislation so it's been a busy
week all round i'm always happy to come
out and talk about what we're doing in
government because we're focused on
delivering for people and getting the
job done in a way that works for people
across the uk okay well of course it's
you know just four days since you were
speaking uh here uh to me but even in
those four days we've had more
allegations coming out around the
publication of the sue grey report into
uh partying in downing street during
lockdown now according to the sunday
times i just want to go through what's
in the sunday times today because it
does feel quite significant
on the night before her report she was
apparently lobbied to make changes to it
this is the sunday times simon case the
cabinet secretary samantha jones the
permanent secretary at number 10 and
alex chisholm the permanent secretary to
the cabinet office are understood to
have pressed grey to water down her
conclusions they go on to say
sources said the case
sorry case's name was among those they
wanted to remove
other changes were requested to sections
of the report referring to the prime
minister's wife
carrie
is that true
i i don't recognise any of that and look
i've got to say we've had a police
investigation into all of these issues
now they've come to their conclusions
made their decisions and we've had sue
grey and i think i don't think anybody
would question the independence and the
probability of either the police and i
certainly have to say as i said to you
on wednesday having
worked with sue gray and her previous
roles and my previous roles i would i
wouldn't in any way question sue gray's
independence and determination to
deliver report that she is comfortable
it is a full and complete report which
is what she's done you say you don't
recognise this
what does that mean i don't what does
that mean i don't know well look nobody
has said anything of the sort to me that
that reflects what what the times have
uh you've just outlined from the time
but with respect though no one's saying
that they were lobbying you to try and
change no no no the allegation is that
very senior people including simon case
our cabinet secretary were directly
trying to influence the report well as i
say having worked with sue gray in other
areas and actually in her car or not in
the report but in her role as dealing
with union issues and things like that
issue grey wasn't comfortable she
wouldn't be putting the report out she
has put a report out that she is
comfortable with she's independently
minded as well as doing this in an
independent kind of capacity and a very
professional civil servant so i don't
believe that anybody in knowing sue gray
i don't believe anybody would be able to
pressure sue grey is putting any kind of
report out that she wasn't comfortable
with the full and proper report the
problem is you say you know sue grey i
don't know see greg
our viewers don't know steve it's too
great we're just basically taking this
on trust
no no you can go further than that
because don't forget it's not just the
sue grey report we've also had the
police investigation the police have
come together and they find boris
johnson for breaking the law they've
they find the prime minister for once
one so that's actually quite good
actually it's good look there's no
denying this whole situation is not good
it shouldn't have happened that's why
the prime minister i think was right to
go out apologize for that i have to say
there were things in that report were
reported we spoke briefly about earlier
in the week around how some of the
security and cleaning staff were treated
it was abhorrent nobody should be
treated like that you're one team
working together for the benefit of the
country whatever your role in is it's an
important part people should be treated
with respect that's why it's good that
this report was done and we're able to
now deal with the issues and the prime
minister's already taken on board the
recommendations from the interim report
and as the final report knows is putting
those changes into place has the has
anyone managed to identify who those
people were who were supposed to be
abusing the staff yeah i have so not as
far as i'm aware i know the prime
minister's gone and personally
apologized to the staff for what they
suffered but i i don't think anybody's
aware of exactly who has committed that
in the first place
but we've got to be clear that kind of
behavior that kind of attitude towards
anybody is completely unacceptable as i
say we're all working together whatever
your role within the government you are
part of delivering forward do you think
that those people should be found and
then sacked well that's something that
civil service themselves and and number
10 i i know we'll be looking at to get
to the bottom of what happened but i
think the important thing is those those
people who are treated that way
know that the senior management there
the prime minister who is himself
obviously the lead um the leader there
not just our party but of of number 10
in the government has made it very clear
it's not acceptable and has apologized
them personally for how they've been
treated um one of the things that i'm i
was a bit puzzled about i said on
wednesday as well uh is the fact that
sue gray didn't investigate the alleged
abenite party uh in the number 10 flat
that was on november the 13th 2020.
this is the sunday times this morning
and they're talking again about the
alleged pressure on sugree another key
passage to be altered concerned the
alleged abenite party in the prime
minister's flat above downing street on
november 13 2020. an earlier draft of
the report referred to music being
played
and then it goes on to say
according to two sources stephen buckley
johnson's chief of staff tweaked it on
the eve of the report's publication a
claim denied by downing street so
what what's going on there what was
there any tweaking if you like if that
well i'd say again uh a couple of key
points first of all see this is another
situation the police looked at and
people were
like yeah i know you're asking about the
sue grey report but but there is an
important fact here that number number
10 down the street is saying this claim
is is not correct that it's it's untrue
and i would say that's backed up by the
fact that the police didn't see anything
there that required anybody being fined
so um i i think the dentistry statement
is a fair statement the problem about
the dining street statement if i'm going
to level with you is that downing street
have apologized for
lying or misleading journalists about
party game right you know the prime
minister spokesman had to issue an
apology saying there were failures and
both what happened and how it's handled
subsequently and he apologized for that
so how can we trust what downing street
is saying it's a bit like the boy who
cried wolf well a couple of things again
i think that first of all it's a
different downing street you've got a
different team of people the chief of
staff is different uh the prime
minister's the same yeah probably but
the team that you're talking about the
team that worked with the prime minister
that lead on these issues and steve
barkley himself is new and wasn't there
at the time of those original
mistakes and issues happened but on top
of that it's not just down history um
denying it we've also got a situation
the police have looked at this this
particular set of incidents and didn't
find an issue there to find people can
you come on this program and give us an
assurance a black and white assurance
that nobody
in
downing street in number 10 or in the
server service trying to implement a
secret report i'm absolutely confident
that's the case look i wasn't part of
the report i'm not part of the number 10
team that worked with sue ground the
report but as i said and i appreciate
your point about the general public
don't know sue grade but those who've
worked with sugar across government both
people who but the question isn't about
whether it was because it was about
whether that
was attempted yeah no i understand that
but i say anybody who's working number
10 knows super very well enough to know
that that kind of wouldn't work and no
i'm confident and particularly number 10
have
outrightly made the point and denied
that this happened i am confident that
sue gray had the freedom to write the
report that she was comfortable to write
and publish okay
now currently 34 mps have publicly
questioned the prime minister's uh
position concept of impeaches 24 are
calling for him to go as soon as
possible that's according to the sort of
sky news spreadsheet that's been
particularly meticulously kept by our
producer tom larkin do you think that
the prime minister is going to face a
confidence vote
i don't think he will actually i don't
think he's in the interest of the
country i don't know if he's interested
in the conservative party and obviously
i'm somebody who was chairman of the
party through the last
prime minister having not only a
confidence vote but i was the chairman
who ran that leadership campaign so i've
seen this from both sides i don't think
he's in anybody's interest no i don't
think we will see that happen the reason
i'm asking is because obviously you know
24 calling from him to go is still quite
below the 54 needed to trigger a vote of
no confidence but as you all very well
remember when the confidence vape was
triggered in theresa may the number of
people who had letters in was roughly
double the number who'd said publicly
that they had had done so well first of
all let's be clear that's
that's rumor of supposition nobody knows
how many letters are in one thing i do
know from having been chairman of the
party i worked obviously closely with
grant brady because you run the
leadership campaign between what's
called the 1922 committee and the party
um and what i do knows there's only one
person who knows how many letters are in
and that is grand brady that's never
leaked i doubt it ever will leak um and
so anybody who's
debating what the numbers were about
they know are today it is pure
supposition isn't that the point right
that we don't actually know how many
letters are in and so it actually could
be a lot higher uh than we think and
then we could also the number could be
hit but it could also be like for
example you talked about the fact that
we've got the sky news list of who has
said different things out there i can
remember a few months ago
one of your reporters at sky news saying
that i hadn't supported the prime
minister because i didn't tweeted
missing the fact that i was the first
minister out on tv supporting the prime
minister so look these lists are their
people have their things that they'll
say publicly i can remember as a
relatively new mp after david cameron
came into government as prime minister
and it was about 2011 2012 we had people
writing and saying they written letters
in back then this is something that does
happen i wish it didn't i think we
should all be focused on getting on with
the job i know in dealing with the prime
minister both on northern ireland issues
and more widely in cabinet that his
focus rightly is on getting things done
for people in the united kingdom
particularly at the difficult point
we're at where people are facing such
financial challenges a difficult point
that's reflected
in some of the polling and we've got
this yougov um mrrp poll it's the same
model that predicted the general
election results and this has shown that
conservatives would lose all but three
of the 88 battleground seats that you
held hold by a slim margin over labor
when you saw that how did you feel
as i've always done with pauline i've
probably said this on your show before
polling is a snapshot and first of all
we've got a fair way to go there's not a
general election in the next few months
it's you know could well be a fair way
away
it could be a fair way away and actually
there's a lot of work we are doing to
deliver for people and i hope by the
time we get to that general election
people will see
two key things one is that we have
delivered the prime minister's got those
big calls right and they'll see a
manifesto that's exciting about the
future but one other thing i would just
say is important on polling it is a
snapshot i can remember in the 2015 gym
election two or three days before
polling day a poll came out that told me
i was losing my seat to labour my
majority actually went up so we have to
remember that you know these polls are a
snapshot the work we do as
parliamentarians as campaigners can make
a very very big difference and i still
think we will win the next general
election and i think that's in the best
interest of the country it's interesting
when you said that a general election
won't be for the next few months is that
an acknowledgement that it could be a
bit earlier than uh we're expecting no
no i just mean this is a poll as of
today it's a snapshot of where we are
today but even if it was a snapshot of
today and even if the general election
was next thursday we've had elections
before where the polls have been proven
to be out as i said i give that example
in my own constituency three or four two
or three days before polling in one
election told me i was going to lose by
a fair few percent and in fact my
majority went up so boris johnson hoping
the same because he's down to lose his
seat well and actually if you remember
going into 2019 there were reports that
the prime minister was going to lose his
c and that didn't prove to be the case
you know he's a good member of
parliament i think he's a superb prime
minister and if you look at these big
decisions whether it's ukraine or
through covid he has got them right and
i think that is what we need in our
country uh now on friday boris johnson
amended the rules of the ministerial
code to make it clear that ministers
won't always be expected to resign for
breaching it and before um doing this
program my on twitter i asked if there's
any questions that people would like to
ask i know twitter is you know twitter
but still
i was quite surprised actually because
this subject came up more than any other
andrew simmons he wants you to explain
johnson's rewriting of the forward to
the ministerial code
honesty integrity transparency matter
anymore he's referring to the prime
minister removing those words from the
forward colm norton it would be nice to
hear a cabinet minister answer a
question and with the new minister of
rules he wouldn't even have to resign
for doing so and why is the prime
minister trying to water down
parliamentary standards
well he's not let's remember there's
been a bit of misinformation out there
about this first of all the ministerial
code is updated which is relatively
regularly i'm one of those obviously has
to fill in
all of the members uh ministerial um
declarations and that's updated
regularly as well so whenever it's
updated quite regularly anyway but this
comes from the recommendations from the
from the commission and some of it from
lord guide around what there should be
and this idea there being a graduated
penalty process
people still have to resign if they
commit
misleading the house or something
serious but there there was a request
from from others including lord guy and
the commission that we actually do have
this kind of graduated approach so it
means that if there's a minor infraction
whereas before there may be a decision
if there was a minor infraction in
theory that that's too minor to resign
then there's no penalty there are now a
series of penalties for different
infractions if anybody creates commits
an infraction in the first place labour
calling a vote on whether ministers who
commit serious breaches of the minister
or code should have to resign in other
words they're effectively forcing
conservative mps to put their name
to these changes
it's going to feel quite uncomfortable
isn't it a bit reminiscent of owen
patterson perhaps um how are you going
to be voting i will also look at the
details of what the vote is because
these things the wording of these could
be quite important but to me this feels
like just labour politicking over this
they're just playing games when actually
what we should be doing is focusing on
the issues that matter not the internal
naval gazing at westminster but actually
getting on with helping people as we did
this week the massive announcement from
the chancellor around the support for
people who are struggling with those
that global inflation challenge making
sure we're putting the support in there
as we are in northern ireland at belfast
with the in-laws coming out of thailand
to support people of ukraine in these
other issues whether it's repairing
making sure the money's there if local
authorities repair the potholes that
drive people crazy every day or the
bigger issues that are affecting their
pocket and their families that's what
they want to see government and
parliament focused on i think talking
about the um talking about the measures
announced by the chancellor he also
announced an energy profits levy on oil
and gas companies what most of us i
guess would call a windfall tax but we
can't use that term for the conservative
party for obvious reasons now you
previously said a windfall tax sounds
attractive but it doesn't work
if you quite conveniently change your
mind there no i haven't actually i
believe in a low tax economy and what i
was the point i was making was that what
labour predict were asking for was a
straight winful tax that disincentivized
um
uh investment from companies actually
worried companies in other sectors and
you know actually some companies like
sheriff said that your policy is gonna
just okay let me just as well yeah i
don't know i've seen that but let me
just just finish the point and it also
meant very very little money actually to
go into people's pockets to help them
one of the things that was clear once we
we we dug into this with labour's claims
were completely false what the
chancellor's ally is different
first of all i doubt many conservatives
are comfortable with taxes of any sort
we want to see a low tax economy more
people in people's pockets to drive
growth but we are in unprecedented times
and i've said before actually as we went
through kobe we were there to help
people and i think our track record is
in unprecedented times with a difficult
situation we would do what we can to
help what the chance of that is
different because the chancellor's
structure yes it does put that profit
levy on it's temporary uh it means much
more money coming back to help people
but he's also putting a tax break that
means that if those companies do what
they were meant to be doing which is
investing yeah then they get the tax
benefit that balances this out so it's
not exactly it's not a win for tax in
the sense the labour point it's a much
more structured targeted approach that
can drive drive investment which we need
in that sector but also help people with
the challenges they're facing with the
cost of living due to a global inflation
pressures you're talking about and
wanting to focus on the things that
matter uh to people um the story that at
the concept of party pushing today is
about imperial measurements you know
this kind of classic you know story uh
that seems to come around every six two
months to a year now alyssia cairns at
the conservative mp has tweeted this
morning to say not one constituent ever
has asked for this this isn't a brexit
freedom it's a nonsense
well i've seen my constituency i've had
a different response of what their
people pleased about it and as you said
this is science comes up regularly
through the years people there are
people who want to go back and have that
business
because the government say they're going
to do it i mean eight months ago tight
the times boris johnson is to announce
the return of imperial weights and
measures that was eight months ago
this is you know this is in a week where
as i say we've done some major
legislation for north island we've done
major announcement uh to help people the
cost of living you know one of the
biggest
structural things we've done financially
for a very long time another 21 billion
pounds of support to help people and yes
look there is something in there that's
more light-hearted in terms of pill
measurements something people like look
i'm of an age where i still think in my
brain in two ways i will sometimes talk
in meters i'll also talk in feet uh
liters and points miles and kilometers
and this just gives people the freedom
and for businesses and there are sectors
out there i know microstitch and see
some of the the market traders and the
vegetable traders as well as some of the
pubs will be pleased to be able to go
back to those appeal measurements we're
just saying you now have a choice and
now we've left the eu we can do that yes
it's one of the smaller things we can do
as we left the eu and there are other
bigger things we can do we want to do
but it's an indication we now have the
freedom to make these decisions
ourselves just finally because we are
out of time and how concerned are you
about the scenes that we saw outside the
champions league final last night our
liverpool supporters saying they were
tear gassed
yeah look i heard some of this last
night i think it is concerning i think
we do need to ensure that they are
looking into how this happened it's not
the first time we've seen this overseas
actually and we're very lucky here in
the uk we've got a police force who have
specialism in this area they're very
very good at it and we've got to learn a
little bit about what happened over
there get to the bottom of it but it is
concerning to see that people either
didn't get into the stadium or were
treated in the way that they some of
them seem to have been treated with a
very aggressive approach liverpool want
to see an investigation do you think
that would be a good idea i think i can
understand that i think we will all want
to get to the bottom of how this
happened particularly it's not the first
time in the last years when i was
policing minister i remember overseas a
similar situation and we've got to make
sure that around the world we are using
the expertise that is there and how to
manage policing and the security around
uh
around football matches particularly so
you think perhaps the french police need
a bit more training well i'm sure that
the french will want to be looking into
this themselves it's not for me to get
involved in their domestic affairs but i
can understand why people want to get to
the bottom of this and i think all of us
as you know uk citizens who were there
will want to know that things were done
correctly and if they weren't how we
learn the lessons and how we're all
around the world know how we can police
and keep people safe a big sporting
event